[ THUNDER ]
[ PHONE RINGING ]
>>> HELLO?
>> HELLO CHAD.
>> WHO IS THIS?
>> AH, AH, AH.
I ASK THE QUESTIONS HERE.
>> THIS MATT?
>> NO.
TELL ME CHAD.
>> THIS KELLY?
>> NO, DO YOU WANT TO PLAY A
GAME?
>> OH, NO THANKS.
[ PHONE RINGING ]
>> HELLO?
>> SORRY, CHAD.
YOU CAN'T SAY NO TO A GAME THAT
YOU'RE ALREADY PLAYING.
>> OKAY.
>> AND I'LL KNOW IF YOU'RE
CHEATING, CHAD BECAUSE I'M
WATCHING YOU RIGHT NOW.
>> OKAY.
>> AND BECAUSE I'M THERE, I'LL
LET YOU PUT SOME SHORTS ON
BEFORE WE START.
>> I'M GOOD.
>> I'M NOT ASKING.
>> OKAY.
>> TELL ME CHAD, WHAT'S YOUR
BIGGEST FEAR?
>> [ BLEEP ] FALLS OFF.
>> BUT I BET YOU ALSO FEAR
DEATH, AND IF YOU LOSE MY GAME,
YOUR PRETTY LITTLE THROAT WILL
GET SLIT.
>> HM, SLIT.
>> TURN THE PATIO LIGHT ON.
>> OKAY.
>> I HAVE SOMETHING I WANT YOU
TO SEE.
THAT'S NO.
PATIO LIGHTS.
>> OKAY.
>> OH MY GOD.
NEVER MIND.
YOUR GIRLFRIEND'S HEAD IS OUT
THERE.
>> I DON'T HAVE A GIRLFRIEND.
>> THEN WHO IS ASHLEY.
>> WE JUST --
[ DOORBELL RINGING]
>> AH, THE PIZZA'S HERE CHAD.
BETTER ANSWER THE DOOR.
>> LIT.
>> STRANGE THAT YOU DIDN'T ORDER
PIZZA.
HELLO?
>> THANKS.
>> SHAME ABOUT THE PIZZA GUY,
BUT NOW YOU KNOW THE GAME IS
REAL, AND THE STAKES ARE --
CHAD, CAN YOU GET A PLATE.
YOU'RE EATING PIZZA OVER YOUR
WHITE RUG, AND COUCH, AND I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO SPILL IT.
THERE'S ONE UNDER THE PIZZA BOX.
>> OKAY.
GOT IT.
>> HELLO CHAD.
>> HOLD UP.
HELLO.
>> NO CHAD, I'M THE PERSON WHO
WAS ON THE PHONE.
>> OH, WHAT UP?
>> YOU MIGHT REMEMBER ME CHAD.
WE GREW UP TOGETHER.
YOU CALLED ME EVERY NAME IN THE
BOOK EXCEPT MY OWN.
FERGUSON TODDLE.
>> OH, NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> WE'VE MET.
ALL THROUGH MIDDLE SCHOOL YOU
TORMENTED ME.
YOU TEASED ME.
YOU MADE MY LIFE A LIVING HELL.
>> OH MY BAD.
>> YOU SLEPT WITH MY GIRLFRIEND.
>> SORRY.
>> MY SISTER.
>> OH MY BAD.
>> MY MOTHER.
>> SHE GOOD?
>> MY HATRED TOWARDS YOU GREW IN
ME LIKE A CANCER, A CANCER THAT
ROTTED AWAY UNTIL I --
ARE YOU WATCHING TV?
>> "RIDICULOUSNESS."
>> YO THIS KID FALLS RIGHT THE
HELL OFF HIS --
>> CHAD, DO YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON?
[ FART ]
>> SAFETY.
>> I'M GOING TO KILL YOU, CHAD.
>> OH, NO THANKS.
>> OH, I'M AFRAID YOU DON'T HAVE
A CHOICE.
>> GAME OVER, CHAD.
>> OKAY.